More than three million people have
signed up to storm Area 51 in September
to "see them aliens". There's probably not
any men in black working with
extraterrestrials in the Nevada desert,
what's actually going on at Area 51 is
even cooler. The Air Force originally
bought Area 51 to test the famous U-2
reconnaissance plane, often the source of
UFO sightings during the Cold War. It was
later used to develop America's first
operational stealth aircraft, the F-117
Nighthawk. The secretive southwest
training ranges have grown significantly
over the years, and today they're working
on bleeding-edge aircraft tech for the
US military, like the new B-21 stealth
bomber and the X-37B space plane. These
ranges also helped to develop the RQ-170
stealth drone — used to find bin Laden —and
the RQ-180, it's successor, of which no
pictures exist. Area 51 and its cousins
are also crucial to testing a whole host
of revolutionary, unmanned combat drones
to work with our current fighters — the
F-35 in F-22. So when the motherships do
show up and Bill Pullman leads us into
battle, humanity's best chance of victory
lies in the aircraft being tested at
Area 51 today.
What's the coolest thing the Air Force is working on today? Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI.